what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends yep
hey hey hey what's up everybody welcome
back to another episode of the
unwaxed podcast with your favorite
sisters sophia
and sistine stallone you guys what oh my
you know exactly why i'm pumped we hit
12
000 followers on instagram and i almost
said 12 million
every time we've been okay so we hit 10
000 yesterday
and we lost it and we woke up this
morning and we saw
12 000 but my excited brain
he saved 12 million
you guys every time sophia says we go up
another thousand she keeps saying we go
up another million
so yes she comes up to me she goes we
hit 10 million i go on what
wow and i'm like on wax and she goes
it's not even but yes we did hit 12k
thank you so much for following our
instagram you guys we love it we're
excited
um yeah we can finally do a swipe up i
know
okay i don't think you guys realize that
was one thing that really annoyed us
when we first got our instagram because
we worked really hard on that page but
we couldn't
swipe up and that you had to have at
least 10 000 followers
to do that and so we always had to go on
our normal page to put the swipe up and
the resources
just thanks for making our life easier
in other news
uh i don't know if anyone noticed but
sophia went back to la
yes and i'm sort of getting ptsd trauma
from the last time that she left me it
was a very hectic week but you might
have been a little bit used to it at
this point
because i go often i don't think you
should ever leave me
alone i think we learned that we learned
that lesson but
what i love about this podcast is sophia
and i
really use it as a way to catch up
together for the first time
yeah so i had so many things i wanted to
talk to her about she had a lot of
things she wanted to tell me about but
we said let's just wait
and explain it on on wax and it's funny
because we wrote down the list i tried
not to read your list
and i got like little glimpses but some
of the things i'm i'm pretty excited
about especially one of them
but we can just start with um you go
first
okay well do you want to make fun of me
for what i did the other day
what did you do i called you oh my
goodness
you guys i have never
and cecine can attest to this i have
never done this before
in my entire life no no this specific
thing with this specific reason
i woke up you know when you wake up and
you're just in your feels
i i think it was the time of the month
combined with me not sleeping
combined with um me stressed out about
the jet lag
jet lag all of this [ __ ] was just
compiling up and i just felt
off and i was going throughout my day
like a zombie and i
ended up just sitting on the couch alone
around 3 p.m
and i don't know why but i started
thinking about myself
and i started to think about who i am as
a person the things that i say
the way i act on dates the way i act
with friends
and i started bawling bawling my eyes
out and i was thinking and i was
i was crying because of my personality
so i called sistine
and i said bowling to her do you
think i'm weird am i a weirdo oh my gosh
it's just him tearing up
what the [ __ ] is going on why are you
crying right now
you guys let me just give you a pov for
me
uh she facetimes me i think it's nothing
she's sitting on the couch i have double
chin up in my face from her angle
and she's hysterical asking me do you
think i'm weird
and i go would calling someone to ask if
they're weird is weird then yeah
you're super weird and we're like that's
okay well
it was because it's like am i i think
i'm not right i'm just laughing so hard
but it's more so
i was just thinking about the things i
say on dates and the things i say in per
and i i went out with someone and i was
thinking about my conversation with him
and
i was like oh god that's a really odd
conversation
and then i thought about the way i act
with friends
we're just gonna run over that we're not
running over i'm gonna head back to that
because anyone else catch that sophia
no we're gonna get well you know me i go
i'm a serial dater i think i just go out
with everyone
at this point i just like to you know so
you cried
but i called me yeah what was your
conclusion from all of this well
i called also my best friend after you
just to make sure that i
you were not just saying well you were
saying i was weird because
she told me i'm not weird but don't
change who you are
i think she thought i was weird she was
like no no you know what like
you are who you are we're just good no
but
yeah i mean i think the way i think
through things is just a very weird
mentality
you know what it is and you can you can
say that you're the same way
okay is we are very
extroverted and very quick-witted with a
lot of random things we kind of like the
shock factor
we like to say when we're going out with
someone or with our girlfriend just
something that is so out of the blue
like one thing pops in my mind i'll see
something and i'll make a comment about
it
and it may be a very offbeat comment
from what we were just discussing and so
i was just thinking maybe i'm really
annoying or maybe i'm really weird like
do i need to stop doing that
i say some weird [ __ ] too that i catch
myself on
i mean i think you're weird in your own
right i think i'm a little bit like
serial killer weird
um but we have our thing and it's fine
so for example
oh gosh i i remember i said to this guy
on the date i'm like
i don't i think we were talking about tv
shows i don't really remember
but i had this thought i go have you
ever wanted to like
punch someone and he goes
what do you mean i go just like you have
that moment where the person's not
injured
they're totally fine they're kind of
like uh but you can just go up and like
it's
but it's also in your favor like if you
needed to do it sophia you are preaching
to the choir i know a hundred percent
what you're talking about my confusion
is coming from how he doesn't understand
what you're saying
what you've never just wanted to punch
someone i thank you and i said how i was
like have you ever had like a face
like for me i've said this since day one
have you guys seen courage a cowardly
dog
that grandma oh punchable punchable face
she's
so scared you know who else icarly
the mom the um mrs benson
the liv's she's so annoying she asks for
it she asks for it
maybe that little kid from that movie uh
with adam sandler and jennifer anderson
the one that goes
can we go to the movie she's that little
bridge it's just go with it
the daughter so you like you want to hit
characters not like character i can't
say people
there are people i want to hit but i
can't
i don't want to get in trouble so he
didn't understand what you were saying
no but i was
you know what to be honest though if you
know me and i'm gonna just
disclaimer i don't want to actually hit
anybody it's a joke like i'm not being
serious
but he took it seriously that's lame
yeah and i was trying to make jokes i
was saying like people i don't know and
then i said other things
that might have been a little bit so
ask actually tell me this is scene
because on dates i realize that i'm a
very
loud person on them i'm just a i kind of
go almost
to a hundred percent just so if you guys
can't handle me at my first date then
like you shouldn't
handle me at all and i like to be funny
and i like to be quirky but i think
that's a flaw on our part
you think so i think so a little bit i'm
realizing this sometimes when we go on a
date we try
so hard to sell ourselves on the first
one so we'll pull out our best stuff
we'll try to be
funny we'll try to be understanding ask
a lot of questions
sweet reserved but also aggressive and
powerful and so we're doing the most and
then
we do that for the first three to five
dates and then on the sixth date you
take a step back and realize
oh my god i haven't really let this
person shine or talk at all and then you
realize that their personality is just a
doorknob what were you saying about the
oatmeal
oh yes i say every guy is like a bowl of
oatmeal
right oatmeal is comfortable
it's consistent it's warm it makes your
tummy feel good
but it's oatmeal now what makes oatmeal
special is how you flavor it
season it some guys are just oatmeal
made with water
boring some guys are a little cinnamon a
little honey
some guys put some fruit in there you
know what i mean so everyone has a full
oatmeal
i don't know if that made any sense to
anyone because i remember i went out
with a guy that was a
bowl of oatmeal but just the water and
oats and you said that and i was like
that is
yeah kind of gene like you can eat it
every day but
change it up you're not going to be
satisfied right because it's the same
thing
and so i said this to the guy and i
actually made a point about this because
when you said that we kind of that's our
flaw is that we try
really hard to make sure the guy likes
us or we have to prove that we're not
uptight or however they might have
perceived us
right you know and i said this to myself
i feel like every time i go out
with a guy or a girlfriend every i feel
exhausted
after i come home because i've put your
sis
selling everything i sell myself do you
put on different hats
with different types of people so say
you have one friend group you're
you're this sort of way because you know
it's comfortable for them
or if you go out with a guy you think oh
maybe he doesn't think i'm very smart so
i'm gonna make sure i say
very intellectual comments yeah do you
do that are you consistent with everyone
no i feel like i'm pretty i adapt to it
once i get your rhythm and then i'll go
okay like he likes this type of
chat and this type of talk but
then i feel like overall i'm pretty much
the same which is
i like to say very zany things and i
like to be a dork
and i like to also like fight back with
you i like someone that has a little
fire if i say
oh that was doing it wrong they got the
banter they got the banter and i
but i i think i need to start working on
that which is not
having to feel like i need to prove
myself and try to say
oh i'm doing all of these jobs and i'm
also
this nice of a person and i'm also this
funny and then i'm also can be like this
pretty and then i can also be this
cool it's it's a really fine line that
we walk
because i don't also think that we do
that
at least for me i don't think that we're
constantly putting in people's faces
like
i want to do this and i want to pursue
that and i'm this type of girl and i'm
super quirky and fun
i think we i know for me and you tell me
i have a really bad habit of doing this
is i'll put myself down
to make them feel better so i will
if someone says oh you are wanting to
act the first
reaction that i have to that is yeah but
i'm really really bad like i would never
hire me
and i would always play the mute girl in
the corner like why is that my go-to
i do the same thing even with the
podcast i'm like oh but i i was super
shitty at it in the beginning like
people will say
oh they'll come up to us on the street
oh we listen to the podcast
and for some reason every time we do
sophia and i are literally
screaming on the inside the second we
walk away from this person we're
freaking out
we're so excited but our our instinct is
oh my god why no one listens no one
listens to us
our mom we're really bad yeah but i
don't know why we also put ourselves
down to make other people feel
comfortable i agree with that and so
i think there there has to be a fine
line with being not cocky but
confident but also not self-deprecating
but humble there has to be like a good
that sounds like someone figured that
out let me know but um
i also wanted to mention while i was
home no no no
no no what i'm still on the date you're
still on the date
yeah you cannot just fast forward
through this so you went on a date with
this guy
like trying to avoid it i know i got you
on waxers
so you went on a date with this guy yeah
is there going to be a second date
i don't know no do you think he's cool
i thought he was nice but i i feel like
for me i always say that i can't
yeah so no i had a good time i i'm just
i'm so
it's a one-and-done my personality is
i'm always such a closed door with my
emotions with people that i don't like
to cross that line until i know
that they're a good choice so hey if it
happens then it happens but at the
but did you just have a fun time i had a
fun time out of ten
what would you rate it i don't know all
right let's do a michelin star review
michelin star
no it was it was like michelin stars are
good anyway it was the appetizer it was
a good it was a good starter
it was a good it was it had we had wine
it was great
but you just called him an appetizer no
i didn't call him an
appetizer i said i'm sorry buddy
well i'm in florida so there's not like
any use in california so honestly the
fact
of the matter is all right what else did
you do well this is also what i wanted
to talk about
is um our cousin ryan was saying we're
talking about how our house is haunted
in l.a
big time oh no he's told me stories that
apparently that girl ghost in our house
flirts with him get out of here you're
being so serious you're telling me
the giggling girl ghost is flirting with
our cousin
yes and ryan by the way and this makes
sense all right excellent when have we
ever
heard the girl ghost who were we around
our boyfriends yes okay okay step one
two and when the housekeepers
heard her one time i think
also one of our boyfriends was home or
about with us like a couple years ago
okay um and then
she he said he was like laying in bed
and a light was flickering and it kept
doing it in this like
rhythmic pattern um and he goes
can you please cut it out and he just
stopped
no yes yeah you can ask him it is the
funniest thing ever
he says he like the he'll hear things
downstairs and now he just talks to her
and goes
seriously i'm trying to watch a movie
and then the weird happening stop
yeah i'm not joking so maybe she likes a
little cat and mouse game
i know she likes little aggressive men i
think that's why she was giggling at us
because of that first time when we got
caught and i was with my boyfriend and
you were
yeah yeah so i think she has a crush on
our cousin
that is awesome i kind of he's single
i kind of think this is good for him you
know he just broke up with his
girlfriend
this is a really healthy way to move on
no commitment issues you know
you can really just fall in love with
someone for the personality not the way
they look
yeah exactly wait well also you can talk
most of the time and they'll listen
they're great listeners great listeners
yeah
so good for him ryan ryan
got yourself a dime and you didn't even
find her on a dating app
let's go i know let's go um
okay so you went on a date our house is
haunted
any other la updates yeah no i thought
this was kind of um i haven't really
talked about this too much on the
podcast but
i got my heart checked just like i do
every single year
um and results results everything is
good fabulous let's go until next year
love to hear it um i've been going to
the same cardiologist since i was two
months old which is crazy and he
has a chart from when i was 10 years old
so i can see
how much i weighed my height like what i
was doing that year he likes to write
down facts of what was going on it's
just funny to see like sophia got an a
on her spelling test
no yeah it's really really cute um but
it's kind of crazy i don't know if
anyone's i haven't really gone into it
before but
i had two operations i had one when i
was two months old
at a hole in my heart and then i had my
second one when i was 16
and it's kind of crazy because that was
in 2012 and next year is going to be my
10-year anniversary since my last
heart surgery which is 10 years ago
sistine
whoa 2012 and now next year's 2022. i
swear you're like an 18 year old i know
i know is that no it's hard to put in
that because you were with me through
that
that was the worst time of my entire
life it was bad it was really scary
i mean i could not understand or ever
imagine what you were going through at
that time
but when you were going through your
second heart operation as a 16 year old
i just remember i was in eighth grade i
was taking my final exams and then i
went from there
to the hospital and i saw you post
operation and i will never that image is
burned in me
for life seeing the tubes in your neck
seeing you white as a sheet of paper
it was terrifying yeah it was really
scary to see your sister in that
totally and i should yeah and i remember
seeing everyone's faces you're so sweet
and you'd lay
next to me in the bed and i just
remember how yellow i looked which was
crazy after the operation
but um i my second one i had an aerix
stenosis and cysteine knows the story
but to give you the lowdown i
am a very active kid we both were very
active kids we very healthy we did every
sport
um we did kickboxing classes four times
a week after school
yeah we did gymnastics we were in ev
every single
physical activity sport anything was
us we would get those little medals in
middle school like ranking us
like we got second or first place that
was great um
and i remember one week i was feeling
extra lethargic extra tired just
really light-headed my heart was racing
at random points i really couldn't like
lay down correctly and there was a lot
of little things that just wasn't
normally there and so i remember
where the final straw came was when i
was at my volleyball practice
and i just wanted to do i would do i
think we're just doing warm-ups or
running
and sprints or something like that and i
almost fainted and i just like kind of
collapsed and i like
clutched my chest and in that moment i
told my
the volleyball coach like i need to sit
down i called my mom
and we didn't have an appointment to go
get my heart shocked until a couple
months later
and i said i have a really bad feeling
and you just know what
i just knew and it was weird because i
was like it could have been
like a virus well everyone around you
your coach everyone was sort of like
okay sophia
you're just making up excuses you're
fine exactly but i've never had this
because i was such
i was such in shape i was so in shape so
i did not
think that it could have been anything
but my heart because i was like there's
no way that this is just randomly coming
up
and then i had to have my second
operation pretty quickly after
and everything's good now but it was
really scary at the time just because
i remember everyone around me was
terrified
and they were my mom was breaking out in
hives my dad couldn't cope with it
i mean everyone we knew and their dog
was donating blood to you
for this operation it was a very very
intense time especially when i was only
in
his sophomore year of high school you
know was it software 2012 what was your
sophomore in high school
sophomore in high school or freshman
high school and
i made it a point to not
show that i was nervous so i barely
cried about it i
really didn't complain about it i just
kept saying you know what i'm gonna be
fine i'm gonna be fine
and i remember the moment getting
wheeled in and when everyone was kind of
not around me
right before the operation i start
crying because i was like i'm just so
you know when you it pens up and then
all of a sudden
it's so releases yeah well i remember
mom would tell me all of these things
obviously not in front of you because
she didn't want to
freak you out more but it was at that
point she goes
she needs to go on a date first like her
life is not about to be normal after
this operation like you were just
a freshman or sophomore in high school
like you should be going to homecoming
which you couldn't do you should be
going to the football games that you
couldn't do like your chest
bone was sawed open yeah yeah so she
goes i gotta get my baby
she needs to have her first kiss she
needs to go on a first date like she was
so
scared and sad that obviously you don't
want to think the worst but you always
have to
so that was just a tremendous thing and
it you know i don't regret it cesina
actually i have to give you credit she
made me confident about my scars
because i was always thinking i have a
ton of scars on my chest pounded it into
your head
for years for years he did you know why
because
if someone i feel like insecurity stems
out of
how you think others are obviously going
to perceive you and
you looked at your scars as something
extremely ugly but i looked at it as
you [ __ ] did that right you survived
it you walked
post the day after post surgery i mean
it was
you were so strong so i'm like hello it
looks badass
and if i could i said i kept saying for
years i said i wish i could trade with
you
i know you i think the scars look so
cool
yeah what did i say they look like you
always told me i i
remember when i was in high school and
it was at the time probably the wrong
guys and they were like made me see like
the chest
i don't know whatever and sistine was i
was like see what if they make a comment
on it what if someone
says something embarrassing or she goes
tell him you were in a shark attack
yeah and i said live i should lie just
say you're in a shark attack maybe it's
the coolest scenario or what did you say
a sword fight
so you say you should see the other girl
yeah yeah she said
you should see the other girl jumped in
a parking lot at knife point
yeah yeah why not so you bungee jumping
accident
they put me back together perfect
perfect so if you guys have scars just
use those
but you know overall everything is good
now which is great and it just has
taught me two things which is
value your health literally the health
as well
you're sitting here listening to this
podcast and you don't have a
cold you don't have an injury there you
don't have anything going on with your
body that's really that off
be so grateful like think about when you
have a runny nose how annoying that is
and you just think about just that minor
thing
can just mess up your mind or when
you're actually super sick and you can't
get about out of bed and all you want to
do is
get up and that made me prioritize my
health and
showing that life is so fragile
delicate because you never know i
couldn't there was a possibility like
something could have gone wrong in
surgery and i would have never had my
first kiss my first prom
like going to college like knock on wood
yeah i know you're good
you're healthy all good in the hood so
i'm really happy to hear that
thank you so you don't have to go back
for a year not for a year
and i actually look forward to going
every year it makes me happy just get
checked it kind of
it gets me a little nervous but at the
same time i it makes me feel good to
know
that everything keeps getting the
positive results go sophia nice job
heart keep it going
thanks keep going heart keep going
now let's transition into you since
christine has been telling me
for the past literally three days
straight saying
i have so much to tell you but i can't
tell you until the show i'm like oh my
god and she's like we're going
out tonight to this certain restaurant
and we just need to go and be ready i'm
like well here's
the thing the problem is i feel like
a complete dick wad why for following up
my weekly update with your extremely
sentimental personal story now i'm about
to talk about
like no this is watching youtube videos
and
i feel like such a dodo go i want to
hear about it mine was too sentimental
so i want to get this just too personal
and just connect it too much
um well i'm very happy you're back
thank you because i don't know if you
guys remember a few episodes ago um
episode title christine's worst week
sophia left me
here we are again left me for another
week was this another worst week
it wasn't as bad but i just kind of want
to tell you everything that i did
it's going to be like a little girl chat
i'm just going to tell you everything i
did
and go ahead we can cut this i don't
care why do you say that see once again
i'm going to keep this in there for
specifically she cut herself down again
no okay i want to hear about your week
let's keep it upbeat um
where to begin oh i also had an
appointment
for what not the same kind of
appointment
what was it i went to the gynecologist
nice i'm laughing because sofia talked
about
how she went to a cardiologist and i'm
like i went to a gynecologist
so personality personality check
no i mean how was that because oh my god
i feel like you've always been very
weird about that stuff
i'll tell you why i'm weird about the
guy now yeah i haven't gone in two years
because i just don't like it um and
i think you know everything is good
in the hood with my with that you're
going well my bits
you also don't do enough for it to be
concerning right i'm
no you're a good girl i'm a good girl
she's a good girl i swear
god what are we trying to say geez
anyway so i met the guy now and i had to
find a new doctor in florida
right so i go all this way i meet her
she's super cool but i requested a
female doctor because i don't know why
there's nothing wrong with a male
gynecologist but for me
it's just a preference thing it's like
having a male masseuse or just whatever
you are
actually i agree yeah so i just
preferred a female gynecologist so
i'm sitting there and it's fine and
they're like okay take everything off
and then put this you know
toilet paper on and go okay and uh
she put the toilet paper she goes i
could tell you're
like hesitant because i don't know if
anyone's ever gone or any of the male
listeners out there
you basically have to prop your feet up
um
in like syrups and literal stirrups and
um
well you're spread eagle fully spread
eagles holy spirit
my knees just were connected like they
didn't want to they didn't want to open
it gets pretty chilly it's chilly it
does it's drafty and
what i thought was so interesting i'm
sitting there and i'm clearly just
uncomfortable because it's just an
awkward situation to be in
but i don't know why a voice in my head
was like
point of view you're at the gyno and i
just wanted to give
you like a point of view okay here it
goes i hear it
honestly i feel like your experiences at
the gyno is way more entertaining than
my experiences because
it's just you're tweaky with this stuff
i'm so tweaky and the funny part is
you're sitting there spread eagle drafty
you know
there are legit tools and turkey basters
going into you
and this is your thanksgiving right and
she's just talking as if
you know we're at the spa getting our
nails done and it's so
funny because her face is literally like
in my crotch
and she goes oh so you do a podcast like
what's your
and it's sweet because she's trying to
make small talk but if you feel
comfortable
right but if you really take a step back
and look at what we're doing while i'm
trying to explain
uh my education and my podcast and my
relationship with my sister
i'm like yeah i mean it's just so
awkward
it's great it's it's just
i mean was it good results everything's
fine
i don't know oh no everything's good
well we'll be back next week to let you
know the results results are in
no yeah everything's good um what else
happened to me i
oh my god i went to the market with dad
the other day
which is just a big mistake i don't know
why shopping with sly
is so hard hard he is such
80d he does so and he barely goes to the
grocery store so when he does go he
thinks it's disneyland
he thinks it is wonderful rolling up and
down the aisles like really walked his
chocolate oh my god he's like oh
biscotti love that oh
sausages love that i mean he's just yeah
nice like he just wants everything i
went yesterday last night and he was
like can i go with you i'm like no
no you can't go and he was grabbing
everything the last minute when i
got at the checkout it's like he's like
a four-year-old you say
i gotta go run get these three things
stay here
i will be right back yeah ten seconds
later turn around
gone you have to have a leash on him so
frustrating so
i'm at the grocery store we're going to
check out
and he's standing right behind me i'm
putting all the things on the
on the counter counter right and
this girl who's checking us out is
giving me these looks like
oink oink and i go what she keeps kind
of smiling at me
and sort of nodding her head towards dad
and i was like oh yeah okay yeah yeah
because everybody usually is
people referring like oh that's your dad
that's like right yeah and then she says
so how does it feel and i go well
how does it feel oh well it feels like
he's just an annoying dad like that's
just my go-to like oh
he's just my dad and she goes
like daddy no i go no
what no and she goes
oh he's you're actually your dad and i
go what did you think and she goes i
thought
you were his girlfriend are you
are you oh are you [ __ ] me sophia
did you would
i i've never heard of that in my entire
was appalled
i was bamboozled what were you wearing
were you like dressed more mature yeah i
was wearing like gym clothes
it what it did not make sense ago there
is at least
40 years between us what are you
watching girlfriend it has to be oh yeah
it is
girlfriend it is wait
so did you tell dad this yeah he thought
it was hilarious
he goes yeah that's right i was like no
oh my god
wait i have a i mean there's
come on like come on read the room does
this look like
she's dating him i look 16 with makeup
you don't
act like you're in a relationship so i
said
absolutely not she goes well you know
we like punch him and stuff we like i
know and she does [ __ ] she goes well you
know
hollywood it's very common in this
business and i go
just
jennifer lost it in other news another
thing we lost it on i know
um i'm just pinballing all of my places
i get a dm
the other day from a cat's
instagram account named
like [ __ ] what's the cat's name like
gumdrop or something like that i don't
know
something like that okay it's kind of
cute yeah and
the cat says hi meow
because of course that's what i have to
talk about is talk on dm it said hi meow
i'm mabel's sister yeah did you hear
what i just said
you just me out the cat said i'm mabel's
sister were from the same litter
no i found my cat's sister oh my god
they look like twins stop i swear
stop so being a cat mom finding the
other sister i mean
lost my mind i know wait wait where is
this cat live
i don't know you should check i don't
think honestly i feel like mabel would
be pestering her sister mabel's doesn't
like
anything but it's kind of like a parent
trap moment it is a people you know what
i mean i was like oh my god
i'm like separated out the fact this is
how crazy
instagram is today we were able to
reunite
cats yes yes so i think we need to have
a 10-year reunion did you answer back
no but i'm going to you have to i know
you should send a photo of mabel
you're right i should you should oh my
god maybe we could facetime maybe we'd
make an account for maybe actually mabel
doesn't like
any photos we're running too many
accounts we are running accounts
our fake account or my fake account oh
yeah sophia's stocking accounts
i've actually decided that i feel like
people are catching on and i need to
delete it so i haven't been using it as
much we saw the
funniest tick tock the other day that
was sophia to a t
it said something like girl goes out on
a first date with this guy
and then she goes acting as if she's
never heard the band before that he
likes oh no no
she likes the band that he likes to
listen to no it was something like
uh acting as if she hadn't already
stalked his entire instagram and his
families and his grandma's face it's
that trend where
it looks like they're about to have a
conversation she goes oh that's cool you
went to
bora bora a couple years ago and it
pauses and it has this music in the
background
and there's a list of things that she's
done i already knew that you were on
that trip i went on to your linkedin and
i found your grandma and i already had a
conversation with her on the phone
that is kind of so funny so funny oh
okay so
another thing that happened is this the
one that i've been wanting to hear about
oh my god yeah okay this girl has been
hyping me up to this story for the past
three days and i'm ready to hear it
sistine well it sort of involves you
what do you what what do you mean
involves me well the best part
or one of the best parts about having a
sister is you get to built
in wingman so what i'm going down i'm
sure i can you with me what did you do
what did you do no nothing bad but you
do have to come with me so
i'm at dinner the other night that makes
sense why you're so adamant about me
coming tonight she's like we're going
out and she never
says this you don't think i just want a
little gno with you no
i mean we have had those moments but
most of the time i've never seen you go
we are going outside okay perhaps
there's a little reason behind it
go so i'm at dinner the other night and
are you with i'm with mom and dad and
we're sitting
at a bar so we're eating at the bar
seating
and okay if i know the place yeah you
know the place
and um this guy sits next to me on my
right
and my mom and my dad are on the left
and i don't
really look at him until he says
something
because i'm pretty sure he we ordered
the same food but i'm pretty sure he ate
my salad because i got there first
and he got his salad first so he said to
me
oh is this yours and i was like no you
can totally have it
rewind rewind you're giggling
so um can you explain what he looks like
or at least um
all i remember he's he's got these
werewolf blue eyes
yeah nice yeah he looks like a golfer i
don't know he's wearing golf clothes i
think i've been watching vampire diaries
so
oh my god that's a whole topic i want to
get in maybe another episode wow
now wow no keep going so i give him my
salad right and i said yeah you can have
the salad
i wait patiently for mine no big deal
he's cute
but then that sort of opened the door
for him to start talking to me
and i'm not mad about it so now i'm sort
of talking to this guy but
i'm sitting a little bit uncomfortable
my body is
straight in the middle because i don't
want to fully turn my back to my parents
and talk to this guy
but i also don't want to turn my back to
this guy he's trying to make
conversation with
me and you know so it was almost like
i'm trying to flirt with someone
with mom and dad listening to my
conversation they were they listening
yeah they were dead ass quiet their
little sneaky little bastards were
trying to hear what was going on
honestly credit's the guy for that's
what i wanted and i
like that balls kudos i mean
he fully knew that they were my parents
because he was asking when we moved here
and i said oh they moved
they he knew it was my parents so i just
felt a little bit of uncomfortability
with the fact that i was flirting in
front of mom and dad
but they were cool they didn't say
anything they sort of kept their
chill until until
the guy starts laughing at something
behind me and i was like
what so i turn around and
sly i already know thinks it would be
funny to go outside go to the
the window of the restaurant and press
his face up against it
and start smearing his face on the
window and then he puts binoculars up to
the window as if he's watching us stop
and i go oh my god and this guy like
he's mature
he's probably 30. i was and you're
trying and you're
trying to be mature as you can with
parents around i was dying
oh come on dude why is my dad my [ __ ]
block right now
come on so he was cool he laughed about
it
and it's great great and
uh remember how i taught you guys my
flirting techniques a few episodes back
i put my hand out first i introduced
myself first and
i said what are you doing this weekend
i put it out there and he goes oh let's
meet here and i'll say great i will see
you then and then i asked his name again
and then i dipped wait okay
great move didn't do what i did which is
burn holes in your head well he's a bit
you i could tell he's a little bit shy
i like that i like a little you know
what i think he was trying to be
respectful
you came in which was good he you had
the parents you had the whole
dad being a doofus behind you so of
course he's probably gonna be a little
hesitant
but you made the move gotta make the
power moves make the power moves
also what does this have to do with me
though just me
being there to wing woman you is that it
i cannot simply go
alone to a ball oh i was like i hope you
you didn't say that you're gonna set me
up on a double date i was like no no no
no
no you're just gonna come with me we're
gonna suss it out if we
don't like the vibes we're going to tuck
and roll out of there yeah yeah yeah
i'll talk to him i'll hype you up
okay good yeah good good this is
exciting this is exciting
you know what when you and i go out on
the town together it really is
so much so much fun we there's things
that happen that we just don't play when
we don't plan it though the best
it's always when we don't plan it it's
the best um i'm excited should we talk
about how
i blew up on tick tock yet again hell
freaking yeah
once again sis i will take the applause
she has cracked the tick-tock code thank
you
thank you and why don't you just drop
how many people actually watched it
to well i would like to preface am i
using my parents for clout
yes i am would you do the same yes you
would
let me tell you it worked like a
freaking charm
and honestly i was not expecting it i
there's a trend going on
my parents or my mom in the 90s and like
hot in the beginning and then your
parents like
bomb thank you yeah so it was my parents
in the 90s and then i just did a
slideshow of mom and dad in the 90s
and i mean the numbers this app is
unlike anything i've ever seen she woke
up and she
i could not believe it i think i posted
this video with 800
000 followers from the last video i did
with my dad
and now i'm at 1.7 million wow
the video has 48 million views
and 7.7 million likes
i cannot believe the power this app has
the numbers it's crazy
it's crazy and so now i'm back in that
place where
i finally got over my insecurity with
tick-tock
and feeling like i'm gonna get roasted
for everything i saw her blow up and i
was like
this app is powerful i made myself one
yes sophia made a tick tock i mean tick
tock i have
50 followers and on waxed tick tock and
on
access to tech talk called unwax podcast
go follow it you're going to see a lot
of really fun clips that we've been
making
yeah um some new some old but i'm going
to try to do
i'm going to really try my best to post
often
and not read any comments i'm really
going to try and tic talk has a problem
with their comments
yeah they try to [ __ ] on you but it's
okay as long as i don't read them i
won't ever know and i won't ever care
it is kind of crazy when when i woke up
and i saw how many likes and followers
and all that stuff
surging into your instagram two from
tick tock she
blasted a great amount of followers and
the perfect demographic which
i'm gonna say is so lucky because i feel
like a lot of our followers
are tending on the men's side but
it really shows you how crazy this whole
social media world is and how important
is honestly if you're in this
entertainment industry to actually get
on all these apps
and i used to kind of [ __ ] on it going
like no no no you don't really need it
right but you kind of do i mean if you
have you need at least like two or three
ones that you actually use it's true and
we have youtube we have instagram and
now
you have tick tock it's it's kind of
uh hmm why it's a lot of pressure
i don't know why it sounds so stupid to
say oh my god it's a lot of pressure and
i'm here sitting like oh my god
i have so many followers i need to chill
out
no but if you actually think about the
people that have legit numbers on tick
tocks
above the 10 million but it's still
scary i don't know i don't know how you
guys do it
downgrading what she just said you
searched from 800 000 followers
to 1.7 million followers scary which is
crazy and it is pressure actually tick
talkers that are big have you even
mentioned
saying that once they have a blown up
tick tock
they have this pressure to do it again
they're like because what if it just
the next five fail yeah mine are gonna
freaking
fail we'll try our best we have some
ideas i'm trying to learn from sistine
by saving some sounds
honestly i know me mine are going to be
very dorky and probably
awkward and probably a lot of book
recommendations that's what yours is
going to be
yeah it's going to be a lot of book
recording if you want that
but i think it's really cool that you
blew up on it oh thank you i actually um
brought something in for you today see
also why did you write down you found a
velociraptor
in florida i didn't find a velociraptor
in florida
so what is this just when you i just
wanted to share just when you thought
florida couldn't get weirder we got
turtles on the sidewalk
now a woman in florida is claiming that
she saw a velociraptor in
her front yard and there's mine no it's
on daily mail cnn all these places
picked it up
uh there was this i swear i saw the
video footage at three in the morning
this velociraptor just running across
her front yard and everyone's saying yep
it is dinosaur 2021's turning out to be
a very interesting year
now caitlyn jenner is running for
california governor you know what
look at this why not why not i think
that's what we got to start saying
when something crazy happens why not why
not what else is
what's next all right i did um a quiz
on buzzfeed and it's
the it was it was called something like
this test will show if you're on this
earth or not
i don't even mean it's about the mandela
effect and basically they were saying if
you can get at least
six out of the 12 then you passed
i got zero correct on this quiz
and okay so i'm gonna get the i'm gonna
get the correct definition for you guys
so i don't
nice i'm gonna get the correct
definition if no one knows what the
mandela effect is
it's a collective of false memories
conspiracy theorists
use it as a wait conspiracy theorists
believe that there are alternate
universes present in society while
doctors
are just saying no bro it is just an
illustration of how
imperfect memory can be how you can just
falsely believe anything you really want
to okay
so i thought it would be interesting to
put you
to the test sofia so what this will show
me if i'm
if i'm actually here or not no i just
want to see how
well your memory is and how you can i'm
going to show you basically a series of
photos
and you're going to tell me how you
remember it okay maybe there can be a
little prize
if you win okay okay okay i've brought
in some pictures
oh i said you say fries i meant to say
prize but
i like fries too i'll give you give me a
prize of fries
if you win i will give you some french
fries how does that sound yeah
okay are we ready
[Music]
oh my god you actually brought in photos
picture number one
i'm holding up fruit of the loom yeah
now one
has a cornucopia behind the label and
the other one does not
how do you remember it cornucopia
incorrect
there actually is no cornucopia in the
fruit of the loom label
you were zero for one are you serious i
swear i know i thought it had a
cornucopia too
okay picture number two we have pikachu
looks exactly the same in both images
except one
it has a black stripe at the end of its
tail
correct yeah pikachu does not he does
not have a black stripe i thought that i
was like i
would have remembered that distinct
picture number three we have
mr monopoly man himself and he's he's
wearing a monocle in one and he is not
in the other one
did he have a monocle no
correct seriously i did not get those
right yeah
i thought you know i because i was
trying to remember if
i don't know i'm gonna keep going number
four we have kit kat cat
is there a hyphen i threw a couple yeah
there's a cat hyphen
there's no hyphen kit kat i know there's
no hyphen in kitkat i swear
this one's my favorite all right number
five we have
curious george the monkey oh okay what
do you have a tail or not
did the monkey have a tail did kyra
george have a tail
to be honest i feel like it's no but
because this looks like this was added
on
but do you remember him having a tail no
i didn't
honestly okay correct he had no tail no
tail
i know i don't remember him having to
okay so far you're doing way better i
actually think i'm
just really intuitive and smart and
aware
whatever what's next we have jeff peanut
butter
jiff or jiffy it's jeff okay yeah it's
not jiffy
i've never heard of jiffy all right the
last one is my favorite okay
i have a photo of darth vader right
darth vader
now his iconic line
yeah can you repeat it for me
oh god i'm gonna give you i'll give
[Music]
even if you haven't seen it you know his
line i'm going to give you
i am your father so
what is the is it wrong i thought it was
luke i am your father but there is no
luke
everyone just added the luke yes there
was no luke there it's just i am your
father
read the caption it says all he really
said was quote i am your father
damn crazy right yeah that's kind of
crazy so how many did you get
i got a lot right i think i got more
than half right
hell freaking all right get some french
fries i guess congrats for winning sofia
you know what no you know i want tonight
order me an espresso martini that is a
thing in florida i've realized
also what that's expressed in martinis
it's not a thing in california
it's a thing here it's been fabulous i
know well that was kind of cool
you know what i never even realized that
that was i kind of wanted to take it
back to the early sister sister day i
know
those were fun days good old days you
guys back
i'm just thinking back on this episode
um
what's up we kind of just ranted for an
hour has it been an hour i think so
it's pretty good like a little girl chat
i like our little girl chat sometimes i
don't like when we make it so structured
i feel like everything we do is so
structured fair enough well i'm excited
for tonight do you know what you're
gonna wear
sophia and i have been thinking uh we
always would dress up and just sort of
look our hottest we're like okay let's
put on a crop top and leather pants and
try to just be a little minx yeah that's
true
we try to wear things that will
accentuate accentuate our assets our
assets
right but i think tonight we recently
are like you know well let's go classier
well you no it was this
we went um and saw a guy uh not not like
that
just we had a dinner with a family
friend and we were asking him
looking around this room who is the girl
that stands out to you the most who is
the one that catches your eye
that makes you stare three seconds
longer and
he looks around for 30 seconds and he
stops
and he goes that one and we look over
and it was just
i mean beautiful girl she was probably
like five nine
wearing a very conservative outfit which
was
more high neck she was wearing a dress
it was floral it was
very very but it was beautiful chic chic
it was very beautiful
covered yeah and her hair was super
simple it was like blonde
just straight and her makeup wasn't like
crazy it was very
natural there was makeup on and she just
walked
in with a very cool confidence that's
what dad's advice is to us a lot too he
always
says you know dress like this because
you got to leave some things to the
mystery yeah gotta leave some things
we asked him what was about that girl
specifically and he goes
it's it's the fact that she's not
like look i'm all about dressing up like
a little minx i like having
we do we do both we do i love it but
there was something to be noted that
he's like it was like a secret beauty
kind of thing where it was
something it was a bit mysterious you
wanted to know more about it yeah
exactly and she wasn't the i mean look
i'm probably one of the loudest people
in the room sometimes and so consistent
but being walking in with a little bit
more of a
with a covering and like a mystery
something that you aren't like so that's
what we're going to do tonight i think
we're going to try that
version because in florida where we're
at it's definitely not uh
not the little minx type you know we're
going to adopt it we're going to try we
could either look like a nun
yes or a little house on the prairie or
you know
um we go in together little women
little women we're either going to look
like little women
i'm going to scare this guy off at the
bar or we go in looking like
either we're churning butter right or
we're in hustlers
or we're in hustlers we're either
looking like we're there's no in-between
or we're in the movie hustlers oh my god
okay i think we should wrap up this
episode just a little quick reminder if
you guys want us to even though we
didn't do an unsolicited advice make
sure you leave your questions in the
ratings interview section on apple
podcast
follow us on instagram tick tock uh
unwaxed
podcast am i forgetting it any inquiries
send to on wax podcast gmail.com
any bedtime stories you can send there
and subscribe
subscribe everywhere and don't think
that we forgot about this giveaway i
thought of a great
idea for a giveaway and it's a one of a
kind designed by sophia and i
so if you want to win this giveaway make
sure you send a video
of you taking three phones subscribing
to unwax on all three
giving us five stars on all three phones
and we will send it to one lucky winner
thank you guys so much and join us next
tuesday
bye bye
from all of us here at the show thanks
for staying on wax
be sure to download new episodes every
tuesday on apple podcasts
spotify or podcastone.com follow your
hosts at sophia stallone
and at sistine stallone and be sure to
follow the show at
unwax podcast your producer is will
sterling
we'll see you next week